Please, welcome back.
Hello?
Music is so...
Bink, bonk, bink, bonk, bink, bink, bonk.
Bink, bink, bink, bonk, bink, bonk.
For the tan gift, I thank you.
And I saw... I saw...
D-D-Demetrodon, thank you!
For the super tap.
Howdy!
Everybody.
Some kind of pirated Minecraft.
No!
This is real!
This is not even a mod.
Guys, this is actual Minecraft.
Sorry, sorry.
Craft mine!
Speedyfire, thank you!
Chicken donkey!
Thank you for the gift, thank you.
Minky donkey.
No, Chicken Minky, I think, right?
Is that what... that's what...
I think Chicken Minky was the proposed...
...correct variation.
Chicken Minky.
Comfy Magus, thank you!
First we craft, then we mine.
What would the...
Music is so mysterious!
Um...
Before we do this, do you guys wanna...
You're a...
What?
Can you explain why this waiting room was put up at 5am?
Uhhhh...
Why do I have to explain myself, huh?
I mean they're looking extra cute today.
Thank you!
Why do you know that?
Why were you up at 5am, huh?
Yeah, what were you doing?
Why did you notice?
That it was at 5am, huh?
Mint, as your lawyer?
You don't have to answer that.
Thank you!
I am...
Please talk to my lawyer.
What?
What's your name?
Where's my lawyer?
Pylons is my lawyer.
Looking good as always.
Thank you, Sulkin.
Thank you.
I could not sleep.
Oh no!
Can you take a nap?
Do you guys wanna help me be a little girly?
Do you guys wanna help me pick some nails?
I'm trying to buy some nails.
Like press on nails and I don't know which ones to buy.
I want your opinions.
Is that okay?
Of course.
Yeah?
It's okay.
The metrodon is a prehistoric creature that lived before the dinosaurs.
But it's actually more closely related to mammals than dinosaurs.
Wow.
Thank you for the fact.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm gonna pull up the site.
Oh, here.
Okay.
So...
There's this site.
A lot of my friends and a lot of girlies get their nails from this place called Tomato Nails.
Okay.
We can't help you slay more.
You're already dead.
Wait.
What do you mean?
I can slay even if I'm dead.
I can be like...
Slay?
I'm cute.
I can...
But like, look how cute these are.
They're so stinking cute.
And I have a couple.
I've already gone through a lot of these.
Oh, wait.
These ones are kind of cute.
Oh, but I'm not really like a My Melody fan.
Miffy!
Wait!
Oh, I thought they were orange, but they're pink.
Wait.
But they're orange, but they're pink.
I want the Miffy.
Hmm.
What's the brand?
Tomato Nails.
T-O-M-A-T-O-E.
Snails.
Maybe different variants.
I don't see it on here, though.
But I was looking at...
Not this one.
I was looking at these.
I like to get my nails pretty short because...
Like, this is...
This is...
Way too long.
I like...
Like, these look so much cuter shorter anyway.
Otherwise, they're just so...
In the way, you know?
These ones are pretty cute, I thought.
And they're like, pretty normal looking.
They don't seem like they'd be so...
Sounds like a nightmare to type with.
Oh my gosh!
They have...
They make, like, keyboards for people with long nails.
Or, like, they make, like, little keyboard extension things.
It's kind of crazy.
I was looking at these.
Arigato!
I just found out it's been one year since I joined the Wisps!
Time flies!
Thank you, Tanuki!
That's genius.
That's kind of crazy.
Ever wondered what happens when you mix hot lava?
L-l-l-lava!
Which...
They're 40 bucks?!
They're reusable.
So, once you wear them, you can take them off and reuse them.
As much as you want.
So it's kind of a bit of an investment.
And also, going to a nail salon and getting your nails done is way more expensive anyway.
Like... Nails like these would be like... I don't know, like... $150.
Okay, Minecraft.
I can't hear myself think.
Such a hassle, OMG.
I know!
I'm more of a consistent pattern for all nails, guy.
See, I'm not.
I like different ones on each nail.
Slaying men.
What's the drink for?
Also, ham!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you!
Mimicor!
Oh my god!
I can change your profile again.
Membership check.
Oh my gosh.
Nataniel, I love your profile picture.
There's a Teto version of the Lava Chicken song.
What does she sound like?
La la la lava!
Ch-ch-ch-chicken!
So I was looking at these ones.
But they only... They don't show them shorter.
But I really...
My favorite nail is this one.
Ones that look like little strawberries.
I also really like these ones.
And then I was looking at these ones.
I thought these ones were pretty cute too.
I don't know though.
I'm feeling this one.
It's so simple, but I don't mind it.
The berries.
Ch-ch-cherry bear.
Cherry berry.
Pearly pink ones are cute.
But so is Minky.
Stop!
I'm a manly man and have no interest in...
I'm too pink!
Do the pink ones, it's so cute!
Simple is good.
This one?
Strawberry or the first one?
I think because I see these ones as short as they are.
And I'm like, oh, they look good.
Oh, look how cute the ribbon is.
Mint and steel!
I wonder what these ones would look like shorter.
Maybe they'd have to only do one heart instead of two here.
And then less strawberry.
Look how long they are though.
I can't deal with it.
I can't, I can't deal with it also because...
When you get these kinds of nails...
The...
The, this, the, this part.
The tip of the nail is like...
Not, it's kind of thick, right?
So when you're scratching, you can't properly scratch yourself.
And it also drives my cats crazy.
Because I like...
Try to scratch them and they're like, It's not, give it, it's not getting the itch.
Yeah, yeah!
They're so annoying.
Okay.
I will...
Oh wait, and these ones are cheaper!
Gosh, these ones are...
I mean, they're all handmade.
So that's why they're so expensive.
But these ones are cheaper even.
It's a sign.
There's also so many more.
I might keep looking.
I might not even...
Sorry.
These are so pretty.
Oh my gosh, these ones are so pretty.
Wow, the cherries!
Oh my gosh.
Pudding!
Oh, they're pom pom pudding!
Wait, I love this one.
Oh my gosh, it's so stinking cute.
These are so gyaru though.
They don't suit me at all.
What is this?
A reference to?
I have no idea.
I like how they can't put like the character names for legal reasons.
This one's cute too.
Oh wow.
Oh, it's so fall!
Froggies.
Catching a midstream at work.
Well, there's a fire.
A fire?
Be careful.
Oh my gosh.
Forest friends.
Look at the Kirby one!
Wait!
The clouds are so stinking cute.
Oh my god!
Wait!
They're so cute!
They're a little bright.
I feel like they should be a little like more pastel-y but...
Kirby!
Wait!
They're more Kirby!
They went on a Kirby binge.
These ones are so girly.
Wow!
They're like Valentine's Kirby.
Stay safe.
Yeah, for real.
Wait, I love this.
I love blue nails and pink nails.
Okay, we'll play Minecraft in like two seconds.
They do look cute.
When do we jockey the chicken?
I hope we can make a world of just chicken jockey.
Buy them all before the tariffs hit.
I think...
Actually, I don't know where this person lives.
It might be safe.
I don't know, actually.
I love online shopping.
I also was looking at these ones earlier, too.
Oh yeah, see?
Here's the pearly ones I was looking at.
Wait, these are so pretty.
Oh, they have bunny.
Okay, I stopped.
I stopped now.
Thank you for helping me shop.
I'm so indecisive.
I'm a freak.
Wait, what's that in reference to?
Stinking cute nails for stinky egg...
Not stinky egg cute.
Anytime.
It was fun.
Doing a little girl stuff.
Little...
Little girly things.
You know?
Like, um, help me pick out my nails.
I don't feel like we did anything.
You did!
You validated my...
What's the word?
My decisions.
I'm not still looking at them anymore.
Yes, I am.
Okay, I minimized the window.
Okay.
I minimized the window.
Don't lie.
My craft...
I know.
Craft mine.
So let's create a new world.
And this is gonna be our...
Craft mine world.
Minky.
Oh wait, no.
Chicken.
Minky.
Why do I always spell it with a Y?
I wasn't meant to sell...
The door knob.
What the heck?
I am done.
Thank you.
Um, raise your hand if you've seen the Minecraft movie.
Oh, sorry.
It's not the Minecraft movie.
It's a Minecraft movie.
Which kind of scares me.
Does that mean they'll make more?
Raise your hand.
Oh, I'm seeing it this weekend.
I'm waiting until it's on the airplanes.
So that I can watch it during one of my trips to Japan.
So I don't have to go see it in the theaters.
I'm waiting till marriage.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Your first night together.
And you're like...
Hey, honey.
This is...
This is the start of the rest of our lives.
So...
Let's...
Let's start it off on the right foot.
And then you just load it up.
And it just starts and it's like...
When I was a child, I yearned for the minds.
And you just look at each other lovingly.
And a tear...
Single tear drops down your...
Your cheek.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Can we rewrite Metal Gear Solid 2?
Where Raiden and Rose...
Instead of fighting about King Kong...
They...
They instead fight about...
Something in the Minecraft movie.
And then they spend the whole night...
Watching the Minecraft movie together.
Did Kojima see the Minecraft movie?
Did he make a tweet about it?
I don't know, actually.
Okay.
We're creating our world.
So how this works...
Look at this.
This is not a mod, by the way.
This is real.
We watched a Minecraft movie all night long.
Oh my god.
He has yet to see it.
Dang it.
I want to see his tweet about it.
Oh, I guess it's not...
Out in Japan.
Yet, maybe.
Are we in the Matrix?
Welcome.
To Craft Mine.
Look at this.
Doors.
Yearn for the keys.
There's some doors here.
Or...
Maybe not here.
Oh, whoops.
There's like doors.
There's like something going on here.
Hey, baby girl.
Wanna come over to Flint and Steel?
And then there's this.
These are all the different worlds that we're gonna create.
Memory land.
Because...
Basically...
You create...
Worlds.
And then you...
Um...
I don't know.
I don't actually...
Understand all of this yet.
Quite very much.
So first, we're gonna craft our mine.
Right?
So, what we do...
Is we have to go in and we have to find...
Different ingredients to be able to craft different types of mines.
I now pronounce it chicken and jockey.
You may mine and craft.
Yeah!
Oh...
Wait...
If...
Uh...
Wait...
All who oppose...
Flint and Steel are forever hold your peace.
Don't you mine your craft first?
This is craft mine.
So we have to craft...
Actually, I don't even know if you can craft in this game.
Like, it's...
It's very strange.
So like...
This was made for April Fools.
So let's put in...
Frogs?
This is gonna be our first mine.
I hate arson.
So we crafted our mine.
And now we're entering the mine.
We're in the middle of the ocean.
So now we have to escape...
Our...
Oh, this is a crafter.
Can I...
Well, maybe I can...
Maybe I can actually craft things if I use this.
Can I take it with me?
Oh, I can!
Nice.
So now we have to escape our mine.
But we also have to collect things...
That will allow us to make different types...
This looks so normal, actually.
This is like the most...
Normal...
Mine...
Ever.
Okay.
Um...
Everything looks so...
Normal.
Are there any froggies anywhere?
I put frogs in.
No.
This isn't a mine.
It's the sea.
I've only done these...
Like, I've only done a handful of these.
Just to kind of test out...
What the...
This was like.
So, I...
Um...
Have not been able to make the most absurd of worlds.
So, like...
See, for example.
Let's, like, break some of this stuff.
Nothing?
Really?
I'm trying to...
Game, I'm trying to give an example here.
Okay, never mind.
The game hates me.
Oh!
See, there's a frog!
Suspiciously normal.
I know!
It's kind of weird!
It's kind of weird.
There's a frog, though.
I saw him.
There he is!
Why...
Okay.
Why would a frog be in this biome?
Because we crafted it!
It is really suspiciously normal, though.
Oh, look at how many there are!
Hello!
Okay.
So, for example.
I'm trying to show you, guys.
I'm trying to...
Game, please!
Game!
Okay, never mind.
Let's, let's, let's, let's punch trees like you do normally.
This is how you...
This is, this is Minecraft.
No, craft mine.
Sorry.
Okay.
Maybe grass doesn't do it.
It does!
I'm just...
I'm trying to show you guys.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Regular...
This is, this feels like home, no?
Is this a bit?
No!
I promise!
This is, this, I'm just...
It's real!
It's not a bit!
It's not, it's not, some of them, some of the, some of the grass has like a little border around it.
I promise you!
I'm not crazy!
We're in Craftivine!
Not Minecraft!
I promise!
It's different!
It's, it's different!
Sometimes!
Sometimes it's different!
See, look!
I can't craft anything!
I think if I put this down though, maybe?
And then with the lever...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
No.
Hold on.
Put you?
Wait, why can't I, why can't I craft it?
Bring this item to the mine exit to convert to experience.
What?
Wait, how do I, how do I craft it though?
See, this is why I'm confused.
Oh!
Oh, like that!
Whoa!
Interesting!
Oh, see, see, see, see, see!
See these?
These are, these will be ingredients for, for create, now see, like, we could create a, a taiga biome.
Or a forest biome.
Like that, like that.
You see?
It's different, it's different.
Craft mine.
So now, we have to collect, we have to collect different things.
And also, to, to be able to create different kinds of biomes.
Right?
And we also, um...
Whoa!
What is that recipe?
Wait, what?
What the heck is that?
Where's my recipe book?
Huh?
What's my recipe book?
Um...
Where'd the, where'd the sheep go?
We also have to find the exit.
Pink eye.
We need to start to talk about craft and mine and grass again.
It's real!
I promise you!
Okay, die.
Die, please.
Thank you.
Oh, I only have so much.
Okay.
Not you.
You.
Okay, we want the wool, because I want to make a bed.
Wait, what the heck is that?
Wait, what is that?
What the heck is this?
A trophy?
Okay, neat.
I need one more white sheep.
And we got to find the exit.
I don't actually know how to find the exit.
I just kind of...
I just kind of wander around until I...
How do I...
Where's my recipe book?
You got to collect the trophies.
I got to be a gamer.
Sometimes you see like a little pillar in the sky and that's where the exit is.
Look for the giant beacon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The bacon.
No more sheep, really?
No more white sheep?
We might die.
We might die, everybody.
No more white sheep?
Mito Jockey helping me finish up work week.
Good luck with work week.
My partner is a big, big fan.
It's her birthday today, so I would like us mostly you to sing happy birthday to her.
Name is Mira.
Of course, I can sing!
Mira!
Happy Birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Mira!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Thank you, Inazu.
Inazu!
For the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hope you guys have fun.
Let's see.
Frog.
That doesn't help us much.
One white sheep!
Oh my god!
Oh!
He's mine!
I was just thinking, how do I get up there and get him?
But...
I won't let you drown!
Wait, where... Where... Oh.
Did I get it?
Oh, I got it!
Yeah!
We're safe, baby!
Thanks for a great year, boss.
Here's to many more!
Thank you, Platypus!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, we're figuring this out.
What?
It's... It's... It's kind of quiet.
Okay, hold on.
All right, let's see.
All right.
Let's figure this out.
You?
Wait, uh... You?
Shoot, what's the recipe for bed?
What's the recipe for bed?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Yes!
I'm so good!
Yeah!
Okay, maybe we can make some weapons too?
Oh, oops.
Ain't no way.
I never remember any recipe ever, actually.
I think the only recipe I know by heart is a torch.
Hold on.
Yeah, I don't know.
What?
What's my...
I said I have stuff in my recipe book, but like...
Where is that?
What's this?
Oh!
Pathfinder.
Stop hitting yourself when using eye of...
Eye of exit!
That's what... Oh, crafting.
That's what that is.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well, how do I make it?
What did I even pick up that allows me to make that?
What?
Be careful if you're watching that movie with kids.
Oh, yeah.
I've seen them throwing stuff around and everything.
Yeah.
You need experience from clearing the world first.
Oh, okay.
So first we gotta get out of here.
Hold on.
I will sleep.
No sleep for you?!
No!
Wait!
What do you mean by that?
Oh, we're so dead.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Goodbye, cruel world.
Not today!
What do you mean by that?
The exit's behind me.
This way?
How do you know?
Am I getting one guide?
Up that render distance.
Yeah!
Um...
Maybe we'll see it in the nighttime sky.
No, I saw it too?
You did?
They said they saw the beacon earlier.
This way?
Is it not the pagoda?
No, this is where we started.
I'm just casually...
Swimming along.
Will it actually not let me sleep?
Kinda messed up.
What do you mean craft?
Why are you guys saying craft?
Woah.
Oots.
First beacon is very easy.
Is it?
Okay.
Hold on.
Well...
Sucks for my bed, I suppose.
Okay.
Craft!
Um...
So this way?
Is where you guys saw it?
Why is it so stinking quiet?
Okay.
No, away from the moon.
This way.
Okay.
Hold on.
Can I craft a boat?
That's a great question.
I should...
Oh.
I should be able to, no?
What is the...
boat?
Nope.
Boat.
Oh!
Yes!
I'm so stinking smart.
Go away.
Alright.
Hell yeah.
Hello, Minto.
Craft mine?
Yes.
Yeah, it's exactly what this is.
It's craft mine.
Mm-hmm.
Anyways, how is everybody's...
day going?
How are you guys doing?
Everything all good and fine and dandy?
Minto jockey.
Oh!
Did you guys see that?
Over yonder.
There it is!
That's our exit, baby!
Is it in the water?
No.
Is it underwater?
Why would they do that?
Why would they do that to us?
That's so messed up.
Um...
Where did I get this ice from?
Cool.
Okay, well, we have ice now.
So now we can...
do a taiga biome.
Forest biome.
Icy surface.
We even got a little trophy.
Cool.
Craft mine.
Okay, let's leave!
Oh, I'm gonna die before we leave, please.
Three...
Two...
One!
Woo!
Yay!
I hurried home to watch because Oomph told me you're being really cute today.
Who said?
We got mine number one.
What do I do with this guy?
There we go.
Sheep dies?
Cool.
I'll do my best to see you during your moso box meet and greet sakura-kanis weekend.
Thank you!
I do have that.
Get slimed!
I wish I could remove some of these so that we could...
You know?
Let's do an icy biome.
Let's try that.
Floating island!
Wait, what?
What?
Best iris employees.
Thank you for the gifting.
Sick and twisted.
So true.
Just like having to work.
So true!
Ice surfaces.
Not...
Oh, wait.
We get two times XP.
Wait.
What is this going to be like?
Now I'm so curious.
Oh, I still had some XP.
I like how you can just...
It looks so ominous.
Like if you jump off, you'll fall and die.
But...
It's really nothing.
Here we go!
Are you guys kind of understanding how it works though?
It's...
It's neat.
It's different.
It's not at all what I expected when I...
Forgetting something important.
When I...
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, the...
The...
Wait, what?
The ground is like ice, but it doesn't look like ice.
But everything is icy.
What?
Huh?
And then we're floating!
Oh my gosh.
Please don't fall.
Did I just...
Okay.
I thought I lost the lever for a second.
Oh, creeper.
Okay.
This is...
This is interesting.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Okay.
Let's just go along our merry way.
Yeah, don't fall.
This is probably the worst...
Biome to have...
Slippery with.
Or worst...
Map?
I don't know.
Okay.
Press U for upgrades.
Oh wait, so I can actually use...
Oh, I only have nine levels though.
What the?
The first pioneers of flight weren't always successful.
Have you heard of the legendary crabbert?
I have not.
Wait, why am I a wildlife expert?
Maybe we go up top and we'll find...
Uh...
Let's punch some trees.
Sorry your Oshi Haley Joel husband got arrested.
What?
I...
Someone told me that yesterday.
I forgot to look it up.
What did he get arrested for?
Finally, my nemesis is put away.
Where he belongs.
I hope he never sees the light of day again.
For impersonating Minky.
He was partying?
Public intoxication?
Why do I feel like so many celebrities get...
Arrested for that?
Aw, come on Haley Joel husband.
It should have been something more interesting, no?
Come on guys.
His mug shots?
But I'm not gonna look at it.
It will terrify me.
I actually refuse...
To even entertain the idea.
Family dinner, but try not to scare her too much.
Thank you.
Oh!
Hello chicken.
Chicken jockey!
Nice.
I like how there's just like some deep slate.
Randomly.
Oh golly.
Whoa!
Okay, alright.
Um...
Let's make some...
Stuff.
What the?
What is this?
Oh!
Wait, my thing!
Amplified world.
What is that?
Okay.
Um...
You.
Okay.
Uh...
How do I make a sword?
Why can't they give me a recipe book?
This is so rude.
How do I make it?
Two planks, one stick.
What's the order though?
Like this?
Thank you.
Okay.
Very good.
Very nice.
There's...
Uh-oh.
Uh...
There we go.
And...
Throw...
Uh...
You away.
We'll keep our raw chicken.
Aha!
Ha-ha-ha.
Wait.
You know what?
I'm...
How am I supposed to find the beacon in...
This world?
Wait.
Is that it?
No.
I think that's lava.
Unless that's...
I can't tell!
What's...
How am I supposed to...
That's totally lava.
Follow your heart.
Well, I was gonna do that before and I almost lost it for real.
Hmm.
I like how we're...
Kind of...
In the...
Oop.
This is...
Strange.
The...
Slippery ground.
And everything.
How am I supposed to get over to some of these places though?
Woo!
Um...
Okay.
We must craft.
Even...
We must...
We must mine.
And...
Do the various...
Things that the game was designed for.
Get the high ground.
Yeah, I'm trying to get over there.
Yeah, maybe we go over this way instead.
Whoa!
I like the floating islands.
Actually, maybe I hate it.
I haven't decided yet.
Look, there's iron!
See, that would be huge.
If I...
Well, I guess I could...
Hold on.
Let's make a pickaxe.
Somehow.
Guys, what's the recipe for a pickaxe?
Please tell me.
I know you'll be so kind.
And tell me.
Make the ice pickaxe.
Doesn't she know how to...
Nope.
I don't.
I don't know how.
Three rocks.
Oh, here we go.
I'm telling you.
I haven't memorized a single...
A single...
Recipe.
Besides torches.
Because I just have my book.
And I search it.
And it's fine.
I don't really have to.
What mod is this?
It's not a mod.
This is craft mod.
This is what they made for April Fools.
So...
Anyone can play it.
Oh wait, I need another stick.
Come back, come back, come back, come back.
Oh, I memorized stick.
I've memorized stick as well.
And...
You.
Throw away.
Alright, let's get some...
I feel like someone is definitely gonna come after me.
Boonga boonga stick.
Yeah.
Oh, I leveled up!
Wait!
Now I can actually unlock stuff, right?
Oh, I'm scared.
What if they...
What if it, like, drops me into the abyss?
Okay.
Alright, we got some...
So dark.
Uh...
Let's make some...
Torches?
Just in case.
Like...
I guess?
I don't know.
I feel like I'm playing Minecraft.
Okay.
I mean, technically, maybe I am playing Minecraft.
But I feel like I'm playing normal Minecraft.
Okay, you.
S...
Eye of exit.
Oh, we could...
Wait, speed run.
Wait, but I think I have to...
Okay, let's see.
Need for speed.
Maybe...
Oh, pockets?
That's big.
Inventory crafting.
Ability to craft in the inventory!
Wait, how do I do that?
Oh!
Crafting.
Whoa...
Okay.
Need for speed?
Whoa...
What did that do?
Get off a flying star.
What did that do to me?
What did that...
What happened to me?
This is a fever dream.
I know, I feel like I'm playing Minecraft for the first time again.
Pockets...
Inventory crafting.
Whoa!
How do I un...
Crafting table!
Is that the sun going...
Oh, that's the moon coming up.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I think we'll die here now.
I think we're gonna die here for real.
Yeah, now we're crafting.
Uh...
Um...
This is a crafting table.
Light it up a little bit.
I think we're gonna die.
I'm scared.
If I die...
What happens?
Okay, let's get...
Let's go...
Upwards.
What I'm gonna do...
Is...
Hold on.
I don't think I need these anymore.
Oh wait, but I need...
I need two spots.
Oh!
Wait, don't leave me please!
You're my only hope!
Uh...
Okay, we'll use...
We'll use my...
Handy-dandy...
Um...
Planks...
To go upwards.
Like so.
We're getting the high ground.
Any beacon...
Showers?
I feel like it's gonna be this way then, no?
I always hid in the trees at night.
Beware of skeletons!
I know!
I'm scared!
I'm so scared!
Oh my gosh, I forgot that we have the slippery...
The slippery...
Ugh...
Oh...
Beacon...
I'm Crouch, so we should be okay.
Don't tell her, Chad!
Tell me what!
What?
What do you mean there are no skeletons?
There...
I think there are, no?
Because I've had skeletons in some of my other ones.
Um...
Okay.
Let me go...
This way.
She doesn't know?
What do I not know?
Oh...
Very careful.
I think those are chickens.
Yeah.
She's gonna die!
No, I'm not!
What are you not telling me, huh?
She'll find out!
I don't know what you're talking about!
Maybe there are no skellies.
Only Creeper?
I see two of them, I think.
It's kinda dark.
Don't tell her she doesn't know!
She doesn't know!
What do I not know?
I'm scared.
You guys are scaring me.
You guys are scaring me!
Uh-oh.
I'm almost out of...
Block.
Brick.
And...
Jump!
Gosh.
Flawless execution, everybody.
Where'd the Creepers go?
Are they on my tail?
It's coming.
What's coming?!
No!
Don't say that!
What?
What is coming?
I wish it would let me sleep!
Why can't I sleep in the game?
That must be an unlock, maybe, right?
Let's see.
Netherite?
Who gets that far in this?
Uh...
I guess eventually, if you do enough unlocks, you can...
Ho?
You can...
Um...
Wait, this costs zero!
You can play the game normally.
You can scale super fast.
Let's see.
Oh, I have seven levels.
Uh, crops, berry bushes, beehives.
Have a chance of dropping extra loot.
Okay.
We're gonna unlock...
All the basic stuff.
What is School of Hard Knocks?
Take your time when learning.
What does that mean?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Get more experience after each mine.
Oh!
Don't what?
Wait, what did I do?
These seem like debuffs.
Wait, what happened?
School of Hard Knocks is bad, why?
Oh, I can't unlock it.
I can't take it back.
It's hard mode!
How is it hard mode?
Oh no!
Guys, I think I messed up.
But it said take your time!
Um, oopsie.
Okay.
Those are bait?
Your time was taken.
Uh-oh.
I messed up.
Can it become daytime, please?
Game.
I would like to restart.
Oh well.
Okay.
I don't see any...
Creepers.
So I'm going to drop down.
And...
I'm going to...
Run.
Ouch!
Run!
Where did this egg come from?
Okay.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm running, I'm running.
So far so good.
So far we're killing it.
And I...
Oh!
There's one.
Watch out for that guy.
I'm so fast.
I'm speed.
Because of the ice.
Oh!
This is a great area to be!
Nevermind.
This is not...
Wait!
Oh!
This is a bad area to be.
This is very bad.
Wait.
Keep going.
Just run.
Just don't stop.
Unless you reach the end.
Of the edge.
Dust.
Oh boy.
I can keep running.
Wait.
Oh!
The creepers I think will not despawn in the sun.
Which that kind of sucks.
Don't look back!
They're all like gathered.
They don't even care about me.
I don't see a beacon though.
They don't care.
They don't care about me.
They're fine.
They're minding their own business.
Um.
What?
And uh.
Where?
Hmm.
Yeah, they're having their own little party.
Look!
We're so high in the sky.
We're about to touch the clouds.
It's kind of exciting.
Kill the cow.
I couldn't.
Actually, I'm gonna eat.
Raw chicken.
Oh!
Made...
I made goats!
From the grass!
Yippee!
Okay.
I wish...
Oh!
I can actually craft...
Wait.
Oh!
I have...
I have more...
Oh my gosh.
I have more inventory.
Oh, this is great.
Let's just unplug.
Hello?
What the?
Um.
Why did I freeze?
My webcam died.
Oh!
My webcam's back.
That was weird.
Herobrine?
He's trying to sabotage me?
Sabotage my game?
Okay.
More pockets is actually really huge.
Because we can do so much more.
Jungle biome!
That's exciting.
All right.
All the stuff we want to keep, we'll put up in here.
Why do I...
Guys?
Um, what's happening?
Hold on.
What's going on with my computer?
I'm being sabotaged right now.
It's here!
Hello?
So weird.
So weird!
He's here!
What if, like, you just heard...
Actually, I think seeing him with no ambiance would be even scarier.
So what does the hard mode actually even do?
Is there a time limit for these...
For these mines?
Makes the game harder.
Like, just hard mode?
Oh, the sun is coming up!
Yahoo!
Yippee!
Halves the XP you get.
Oh, that's so lame!
Um...
Yeah, I made a mistake.
But that's okay.
Alright, I'm running for it.
Move, Cal!
Move!
Moo!
Uh, let's see.
Quit!
This feels like normal game.
I'm just...
But I'm looking for the beacon in the sky.
Looking for any...
What if it's down below?
No, it would shoot up, right?
It would shoot up into the sky.
Right?
Even if it's...
Underneath the ground?
Right?
It's not me who sabotaged, I swear.
It better not be!
Moo!
Oh no, I'm hungry.
Time for kill.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
Oh!
Chicken jockey!
Poor chicken.
Poor me!
I need to eat!
So I can escape!
I don't think I can actually...
Uh...
Cook...
Yet.
So we're just gonna eat it raw.
And...
Salmon...
Uh oh.
I was about to say, salmonella be damned.
But um...
Yep, I just got that.
Wait, what is...
What?
Oh, hunger?
Wait, no!
No!
No, please!
I didn't think it would be true!
Okay, hold on.
Do you think I'm getting too far away from...
From where it would be?
Oh!
Uh...
Let's see.
Maybe.
Okay, we're good.
Now that I can craft a little bit.
Okay.
Parkour.
Actual...
You can make that jump.
I'm a baby.
I probably actually could've.
Especially with the ice.
Should I head back?
Parkour.
I don't know how close it's supposed to be.
How far it's supposed to be.
Um...
Hmm...
My second favorite thing after...
Me though.
What?
Why would that be on your list?
You!
There are infinite exits.
Just keep wandering.
Oh!
Thank you.
Okay.
That's good to know.
We'll just keep wandering.
We'll...
And eventually...
Whoa!
This is so crazy to see.
Wowie.
Okay.
Just don't fall.
I would do no such thing.
Falling into a hole?
Only...
Noobs...
Minecraft noobs would do that.
Obviously.
Imagine falling.
Minky falling off.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
This is fine.
I should probably kill more chicken.
Sorry chicken.
Oop!
Wait, did I get a...
I got a second trophy!
Wow.
This just feels like a participation trophy at this point.
Thank you.
Do you think I'll still get salmonella if I eat this?
Raw?
And I'm getting...
I'm getting XP.
So honestly...
Chocominto.
Ice, ice, ice!
Bring that song back.
As much as I like the...
Doobie-chan...
Song.
Bring back Chocominto.
Ice, ice, ice.
Can't tell...
Okay, there is Minecraft music playing.
Sometimes...
Just doesn't play.
As it does in Minecraft.
We'll find an exit everybody.
I'll get you out!
Trust me with your life!
Do you trust me?
Maybe.
Trust me.
Okay, I'm gonna eat the chicken.
I'll be fine.
Oh yeah, I'm fine.
Oh yeah, I'm fine!
Oh yeah!
Yeah, no poison for me today!
I have...
Oh no!
That's fine.
We're going fast now.
I got greedy.
No!
Why is it on fire?
Oh, the lava.
Guys, I don't think we're ever getting home.
It's a lot of chicken.
Yeah.
Look at this, we're fine.
And we're speeding.
We're gonna find the exit.
Wait...
Oh?
I'm seeing things now.
Like I'm...
Oh!
This is good!
I can get experience.
Experience!
Please!
And...
Maybe we'll get something for...
Yeah!
The iron.
Iron.
Oh!
Good, good, good, good, good.
This is good, good, good, good.
This is only world two, you guys.
I think I'm...
I think I'm screwed.
I'm not cut out for this life.
I'm not cut out for this.
I saw some more over here.
Iron.
You're doing...
Great, Nita.
You really think that?
Maybe once we go through more worlds, we'll get used to it, but...
Yeah.
Might be a bit of a struggle...
At first.
We'll get used to it.
Probably.
And we're gonna get two times XP, because we're on the slippery slopes.
Okay!
Level five!
Alright, we can unlock some more stuff.
Alright.
What should we unlock?
We'll have to go through our little...
Book.
Our booklet.
Whoa!
There's so much iron!
I mean...
A coal!
Iron.
This is an iron.
I made a...
I made a whoopsie.
This is coal.
Black iron.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa!
This is like...
Actually, this might be like the biggest...
Vein I've ever seen.
Actually.
That's insane.
We got almost a full stack from that.
It's craziness.
And I...
It almost led me to my death as well.
Oh...
The world is burning.
Wait, how am I supposed to...
Okay.
Because...
Uh...
This.
I need a...
I need smelt.
I need to be able to...
Do this.
So...
I need...
The thing that allows me to...
Find a way out.
I think...
Maybe we should save up for the pathfinder.
Hold on.
I'll just keep digging.
I'll just keep earning more levels.
Level seven?
Look, we're already there.
We're too good.
Good job, team.
That hunger didn't even do anything to us.
Just keep yourself alive.
It's hard to do that when I'm dead.
What?
Oh, wait.
Didn't they add like these little logs in the new update?
It looks so stupid.
Have you come closer to a decision about redoing your lease?
I'm not thinking about it.
They actually called me this morning.
They were like, um, hi?
Hello?
What are you gonna do?
I was like, uh...
I'll let you know.
More.
Coal.
I don't think it looks stupid.
I think it looks a little silly.
I like it though.
A stupid affectionate.
Stupid affectionate.
If we just keep going straight, we're bound to hit one.
Something.
I don't even know what the recipe is though for the pathfinder.
I don't even know.
Don't fall.
Oh!
Okay.
You're useless.
Give me, give me...
Experience, please.
Thank you.
I need so much...
I have so much coal.
Level eight.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's just keep going for now.
I'm...
I'm a wanderer.
I don't like being stuck in one place for too long.
Please don't make me hungry.
Please don't poison me.
Chicken!
Yes!
The chicken was clean.
Is there a wonder a way to...
I wonder if you can get to the edge of the world.
Okay.
I'm gonna mine in here.
And hope that nothing spawns.
No salmonella for us, baby.
Our stomach has been hardened.
Our...
Uh...
Everything.
Our body is...
Evolved.
We've beyond...
We've gone beyond.
We don't...
We don't need...
To worry about it anymore.
This is the future of human evolution.
Steel gullet minto.
You're welcome.
Iron stomach upgrade.
Can you imagine if they actually did that?
What if we...
Actually, I just realized.
If we unlock the thing that allows us to...
Um...
Just put that out there.
That allows us to...
Cook.
Like, for the iron and stuff.
We can...
Oh!
That scared me.
We can also...
Make our...
Food.
Oh, I need stick.
Wait, I can make stick here.
Yes.
Okay, then.
You and two stick.
Perfect.
Perfection.
Oh.
Wow.
Rude.
Let her cook.
I feel...
Maybe the...
Way...
The path...
We're only on the second world.
Okay!
One more level!
Let her craft.
Chicken jockey.
She isn't cooking.
Yeah, because I've been...
I've been...
Banned from doing so.
This is gonna be a long stream.
What if we just never make it out of here?
I'm stuck in this hell.
Someone...
God, please help me!
As long as I don't get ambushed.
I don't even need the coal anymore.
Please.
Give me the XP.
Just give me the XP!
Okay.
Oh, I heard something walking in the...
I heard something walking in the...
In the...
In the dirt.
You guys hear that?
What is that?
I don't see anything there.
Is it a chicken?
Run!
What's there?
That was actually so freaky.
Chicken jockey!
Wait, we...
What if we make a whole world full of chicken jockey?
Maybe it's down here.
Maybe...
Oh, maybe it's these three creepers.
Yeah, it's definitely them.
You guys are so noisy.
So much for creeping.
Okay.
Uh...
I'm trying to think of what I want to do.
I guess I just...
Let me take this back.
And I think we're just going to keep on running.
After I am gone from this world without the ice anymore, I'm going to be so sad.
We'll be so slow.
Yeah, I think I should just...
Can you make a crafting table yet?
Actually, did I unlock that?
Oh, I did!
I did unlock that.
So, yes.
Oh, I don't really need this crafter anymore, right?
Ah!
That feels so good!
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
I love recipe book!
I don't care about anything else!
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Come here.
Can I craft a...
What?
Oh!
You!
Cool!
Okay, we're going to need... Let's get some stone.
I imagine it'll let us craft it, even if...
It's like...
You have to unlock it?
I'm not quite... I don't know how this works.
It's kind of strange.
Wait, yeah.
See?
We can... We can still craft it.
Hole?
Huh?
Whoa!
Yeah!
Evolution!
Let's make... Let's get some more iron.
We can make...
We can make armor!
Quinta without a recipe book is like a Zoomer that can't remember phone numbers.
You know what?
Anyone else would be offended, but I find that to be an apt description.
I find that to be pretty accurate, not gonna lie.
There's a creeper right there.
We're gonna have to be careful of that guy.
As long as he doesn't encroach on our territory, we'll be okay.
I actually can't remember phone numbers, though, really.
I can't even remember my own phone number.
Well, I'm very bad at remembering numbers in general.
And so, if I get into a high-stress situation, which is talking to people, I can't remember my phone number, and I always have to...
I'll be like, oh, sorry, I got a new phone number recently.
So I have to look it up, even though I've had my phone number for like three years.
I'll be like, oh, sorry, yeah, I just got it.
I can't remember it just yet.
That happens way often.
Same.
I'm glad that we're all in the same...
We're all in the same boat together here.
Numbers hard.
Numbers hard, you guys.
All right, we're really cooking now.
We're really cooking...
Woo-hoo!
Oh!
Ten!
What do I do?
Pathfinder.
Wait.
Oh, we have a recipe book now.
So path...
Oh, this thing!
Eye of exit.
I need copper?
Okay.
Oops.
Let's make some armor.
Just in case the creeper comes up.
I don't have armor slot!
Just kidding.
Abort, abort, abort.
Hey.
Hey, mister.
This area is taken.
Don't look at me.
Yeah, turn around.
Hold it and click.
Okay.
Click?
No.
I don't think so.
Or hold?
Like here?
Ow!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're cheating the system.
We're cheating the system.
Let's go.
The way they didn't think of that.
How is she so smart?
Because you guys tell me.
You guys make me so smart.
You guys make me into a genius.
Okay.
All right.
Copper, I don't think is even possible.
I don't think we'll ever find that.
So, um, I guess here, once we smelt all of our iron, we'll make a full suit, we'll make a sword.
A ship.
What?
Well, I just need pants and feet, right?
And pants.
Oh, I don't know.
Actually, I think we have enough.
And then we'll continue onward.
And I wonder if I can make a shield.
Should be able to.
Let's go, uh...
Chop some tree.
Chop, chop, chop.
Chop, chop, chop, chop, chop.
Chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop.
How goes the craft mine?
Um...
I think we're okay.
Right, guys?
Maybe.
Let it go.
We're gonna make it to world three, for sure.
Trust.
Trust will make it to world three.
What was I making?
Oh, a shield.
Yeah, baby.
I've made it to level one.
And shield.
And...
Give me...
A sword, and we'll be good to go, baby.
Sword.
Yahoo!
We are never making it out.
Yes, we are!
I'm hoping we make it to world five.
Whoa!
We have really high expectations.
You know what?
I love that.
I...
I really love that.
You're like, yeah, we're gonna make it to world five.
Probably.
I love that.
I love that you're thinking...
You're thinking big, lofty goals here.
Let's go slaughter some animals.
Chicken.
More chicken.
Sorry, family.
Sorry.
Wait, I'm not even picking up the chicken.
Uh...
Go wait.
Yes.
Slaughter the families.
Alright, let's cook.
We can actually cook now.
Let me cook.
Love your long craft mine Minecraft streams.
Thank you, Kamenachi.
It's been a minute since we played Minecraft.
I hope...
I hope soon I can play in like a world with...
With people.
And friends.
And stuff.
That's always fun.
Look, we're even...
We're getting experience for that.
Yes.
You can drop the crafter now.
I...
Will...
Keep it?
Just because...
What if...
Well, I won't remember a recipe, will I?
I won't remember the recipe.
I think you're right.
We'll drop it.
I was gonna say, what if I...
What if I...
Want to make something that I don't have the recipe for?
If I don't have the recipe...
I don't know it.
I'm not gonna know it at all.
Some pumpkin.
I think I've completely forgotten what the plot is of this.
Instead, we're just like running around.
I'm trying to see if I can unlock any pumpkin.
Pumpkin world.
No?
Nothing?
Really?
Lame?
Okay.
Copper!
I don't think we're gonna get it.
Wait!
Did I see?
No.
My eyes must have deceived me.
Unless...
I think my eyes deceived me.
Let's go this way.
When you want copper, you never find...
I know!
I think it's just also we're in like a type of environment where copper is not going to...
Spawn.
This isn't...
I think you guys are messed up.
I think we're never getting out of here.
There's no way!
Please!
Please get me out of here!
I'm sick of this world!
I'm tired of this world!
This is where we live now.
No!
Okay.
The reason, if you're curious why I'm not picking it up...
I'm trying to get things to see how...
Sorry, it's hard to tell.
They have like the little...
Not crosshairs, but the little blocky things around them.
That means you can...
Use it as like a world builder in a future world.
So that's why I'm like...
Wanting to collect...
That.
So that I can...
Maybe make it...
Like use it for crafting a mine.
Our next mine.
Yeah, they're like seeds!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
Where's...
The exit?
I think it should...
Oh my god!
Exit!
Wait, this is not a drill.
This isn't...
This is for real.
I see it!
Yeah!
I'm gonna go around.
Oh my god!
We're free!
Wait, don't disappear on me.
Don't...
Don't leave me!
Batman meme.
Oh my god!
Oh my...
Made it out of here!
Is there anything else we can collect...
For like experience on our way out?
You know?
Um...
Oh, this gives us a lot of experience.
I wonder if there's anything else.
Never doubted.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Trying to see what other like kind of material...
I guess I'm mostly full anyway, so...
Okay.
The music just started.
Whoa, it's really pretty.
Let's go home.
Oh, finally!
We're saved!
One!
Whoa!
Yeah, baby!
Oh my gosh!
24!
24 levels.
Oh.
Did I get all of it?
Alright, let's put our...
Now these doors are so mysterious, right?
The door yearns for the keys.
Like...
What...
What happens...
How do you get a key?
What if you...
What happens when you open it?
No way, I got three chicken trophies.
Okay.
No.
No, please.
Please don't be...
Um...
Amplified world.
Oh, I can't do that one.
Mine exits are found on the surface.
Okay, so that's already...
That's already a given.
I guess we're doing an...
Amplified...
Creepers?
Let's do...
Oh, I can't do slimes.
We can do...
Uh...
I wanna get more interesting things.
Hmm.
We lost our armor.
That's okay.
Look, ghasts.
Eternal rain.
Win an eternally dark mine.
What?
Oh, sorry.
If you heard that, that's my cat going into a bag.
Pies, what are you doing in there?
I have...
I have like a paper bag on the ground that she likes to lay inside.
Can you hear it?
Let...
Oh, grid world!
Wait, that's...
That's just...
That's just parkour.
That's just Minecraft parkour.
Jump from really high up.
Okay.
There's like hints on how you...
How you can get these, which is kind of fun.
Walk on this block and give of...
Give...
Of...
A char...
Do you mean off?
Is this a typo?
It's a nice crystal, but not even worth a dime.
Striders.
Please.
There's a lot of undiscovered.
Yeah, parkour civilization!
That's what that one is.
Guardians!
Use 20 of your experience to work towards upgrading the Minecrafter table.
Oh!
Interesting.
Okay, so our base...
Don't step on the pine cones.
What else should we do?
Goats?
Paper?
Creeper?
Little girl, what are you doing?
Goats and slippery.
I think if you don't put in a specific mob...
Like the creeper, then it will be all of them.
So...
You always want to make me happy.
Thank you!
I'm just...
Messing around.
Do the creeper one.
I feel like the creeper would be good, no?
Then we could do...
Or slimes.
We could do slimes.
Oh, I can't do slimes.
Oh, wait.
For some reason it won't let me...
Maybe...
I don't know why it won't let me.
Okay.
Let's try this one.
I don't know...
Oh, whoops.
I don't know what this will make.
If it'll make anything interesting.
But let's try it out.
Slimes are already part of the world.
Ah!
That's what it means.
Slimes are in by default.
Oh!
Whoa!
Why do I have a chicken?
Egg.
Okay.
Got our stuff.
Think I could jump from here.
Whoa!
Oh!
This looks...
Wow.
This is quite the...
Spawn.
Do a flip!
Oh!
Hey, I should have gotten that achievement.
The one that says jump from a high place.
Well, it's raining.
I don't want to get ambushed, but I also want...
Um...
The coal.
That's all around here.
Okay.
Lovely day for rain.
Where are the goats?
Whoa.
Oh my god.
That tree is getting hugged.
By the fire...
Or by the lava.
But it's like fine.
It's not on fire at all.
Yes, it is.
Nevermind.
It just...
Oh, there it goes.
I thought it was the chosen one.
Okay.
How are we gonna find...
Ourselves...
An exit.
Wait, though.
We might actually be able to find some copper in this vile.
Nope.
Goat, bottom right.
Oh, shut up.
She's the goat.
Okay, let's punch some trees.
I thought Craft Mine is a different game.
You tricked me.
I didn't trick you.
Minecraft changed so much.
No!
What do you mean I tricked you?
This is...
Craft Mine.
Oh yeah, we have our 24 levels.
We gotta use those, huh?
Upgrade Minto.
What should we upgrade?
I mean...
Let me punch trees first.
Oh, look at all the little foliage and everything.
Wow.
Detroit, thank you!
I got a raise today.
Congrats!
Also hope you're doing well.
Thank you!
Congrats!
Oh my gosh.
You shouldn't...
Don't send it to me, though.
You should've gotten something yummy.
You should celebrate you!
This Minecraft PGM makes me so...
Emoy.
Me too.
Let's see.
Compass to point...
We could do a lodestone exit, but I probably would have to craft that, no?
The first pioneers of flight weren't always successful.
Maybe you can do better after unlocking the spell book.
We could go faster.
More pockets is nice, too.
Um...
Dirt enjoyer?
Uh...
I don't understand what these mean.
They're so...
They're so vague.
They're so cryptic.
What do you mean I appreciate the value of dirt?
Dirt enjoyer is good?
It is?
Does it, like, give you more...
You enjoy dirt more than others.
Does it give you, like, more XP for dirt?
Value 0.2.
I feel like I got bullied into...
Into taking this.
Does it feel like it doesn't do anything?
I might have been tricked.
Craft mine meta.
Maybe it's one of those, like, you have to keep unlocking it to realize its full potential.
You can get campfire to...
Oh, to start with!
That's kind of nice.
Wait, you are the campfire?
What does that mean?
Don't get the last one.
Whoa!
Team Red!
I didn't get a raise.
I just like Pinky.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
This is a...
I forgot to mention.
This is, like, all...
Well, actually, maybe I did mention it, but...
This is an April Fool's thing.
So, would this literally just set you on fire?
And then...
What does that do?
Wouldn't that be a good thing, though?
It sets every block you punch on fire.
Oh!
Wait, that sounds kind of awesome!
You can cook any raw food that you are holding.
How is that bad?
Wait, how is that bad thing?
Let's keep going fast.
Sneak as fast...
As when you are holding both W...
Oh, sweet...
Swiss sneaking!
Speed run.
You can't turn it off.
Yeah?
You are not fireproof.
I'm still failing to see the problem.
So...
Oh, wait!
So, if I, like, set...
Say I set, like, a...
A tree on...
Like, I try to punch a tree.
It'll just set it on fire.
Like, that's the issue?
I'm unemployed!
Don't send Super Chat!
Yes.
Oh, I can see how that would be...
Potentially bad.
Hello, pies.
Come here, baby girl.
Come here, little girl.
I think she wants out of the room.
Hold on.
Let me go let my cat out.
Also, I'm gonna put on some BGM, because the BGM...
I always forget how inconsistent Minecraft BGM is.
Um...
We'll turn...
Music...
Off.
Even though...
I love Minecraft music, but...
Oh...
Music...
Uh...
What's this?
What did I just press?
This one?
I want something...
Kind of chill.
Hold on.
One second, sorry.
There we go.
This is good.
Okay.
Okay, give me a second.
I'm gonna let my cat out.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Uh...
This is...
This is Andesite, no?
I get paid by Meta.
Oh...
Oh no!
I need a thing!
Ow!
I forgot!
What do you mean you get paid by Meta?
I'm also unemployed.
Stop!
Miss Phantom, are you hiring?
Oh...
Oh golly.
What are your...
Credentials?
I need regular stone!
But everything's...
Not regular stone!
No!
I need stone!
Boy, this is bad.
Wait, we can make it with...
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
I'm stupid.
We can make it with...
With wood.
There, I'll make it out of this.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
You.
Alright, alright, alright.
Dig straight down.
I wonder what would happen.
In a world like this, if we dug straight down?
What would happen?
Unemployed gang.
I don't think you guys should be sending me money if you are unemployed.
That's just...
Uh...
I'm not a professional.
But that's like my...
Professional opinion.
I came really close to getting fired this morning!
Are you guys okay?
Last two dollars.
Please stop.
Always forget to use this.
Oh!
Thank you!
Thanks for six months.
Okay.
Now...
We're good.
Now we're cooking.
Okay.
Ever since we were able to get the crafting table.
Now we...
Now we're cooking, baby.
I'm retired.
Are you like one of those like...
Like 1% of people?
Less than.
Less than what?
I get like sometimes like the...
0.01% that is like...
You know when you look at the analytics and it says like...
Old people watching you.
You know?
Well...
My boss is cutting my house.
My credentials is loving me too.
Do I get the job?
I will.
You can clean the tables at the maid cafe.
If you like.
Okay.
Let's make a sword.
Very nice.
Starting to get dark.
Scary.
Spooky.
Wait.
We're getting slimes and creepers.
Snow.
This is going to be weird.
Thank you guys.
For all this everything.
Thank you.
I want $500 and a March Madness.
What?
That's crazy.
Oh my God.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Money of someone who got a new job.
Congratulations.
On your new job.
I think...
I think if you get a new job.
You should like...
You should...
Like...
Get something for yourself.
And...
For...
As a...
As a happy...
Happy day to you.
Look at the...
I've never seen a baby goat before.
Wait.
Oh sorry.
I didn't hit him right?
No.
He's fine.
He's so cute.
I've never seen a baby goat.
Here.
Watch...
Watch me murder baby.
This is the real world.
That's the real world.
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Wait.
Where'd the baby goat go?
I didn't kill him on a...
Wait.
Was that the baby goat that I just killed?
No.
Wait.
What did I just kill?
I killed a duck.
What?
Wait.
Where'd the baby goat...
Oh there he is.
He's fine.
Look how cute he is.
Oh my God.
He's so stinking cute.
Cool.
Okay.
Alright.
I wish the rain would stop.
Here's the cut of my paycheck.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you.
Still trying to find a new job.
You got this!
You got this, 9-0!
You got this, I believe.
Let's make a boat.
See, I told you, I don't know anything.
What the?
Where'd my boat go?
It goes minted.
Oh!
Eh, ah, eh, ah, eh, ah.
There we go.
Minted.
It's the one thing about having mint as a... One terrible thing, I suppose, about having mint as a name is...
Everything is like a crypto... Ooh!
Things are minted!
I don't even know what that means.
I'm just... That's what... I'm minto!
Not minted!
I can't see anything.
I want to turn my brightness up.
I can't see a single thing.
I don't think that's it.
Oh, that was so close!
Still the... No!
Don't steal money!
I mean...
Unless...
Oh, there's a creeper.
Okay, that's our first creeper.
Are creepers afraid of the rain?
No.
Goat goes minted.
Mint goes boated?
Mint is...
Boated?
Goated?
Alright.
We're just traveling along this little river.
May it never end.
May us only find...
A...
Exit through this means of...
Method of travel.
Fade goes minted.
Dipping into the 401k!
Stop!
Please!
Don't do it for VTubers.
It's not worth it, I promise.
It's not worth it.
Wow, we're really on like the ocean blue here.
I still don't see any...
Oh!
Thank goodness.
Oh, finally.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
I see it!
It's another underwater one.
Wait, I have like nothing here though.
I have like no supplies.
I'm working right now.
My cut of the paycheck.
Tipping into my retirement fund.
Dirt?
Get lots of dirt?
Okay, let's get dirt, baby.
Let's get dirty.
Sorry.
Glad I'm able to send my very first super jet.
Stop!
Shut up!
Don't lie.
Okay, creepers, I need you to go away.
So I can...
Um...
Excavate your land.
Wow, this one was so fast.
We're so good.
Wait, let's get a bunch of flowers maybe.
Instructions unclear.
No.
It's worth it to see your smile.
Or your cries of anguish.
There's no tags.
I think it's okay if I use my company credit card.
Can you invoice me?
Oh no.
Um...
Yeah, maybe.
Guys, try and remember...
Oh!
Wait!
Cherry Blossom!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa!
Cherry Blossom!
Try...
Remember, it's over there.
Okay?
Cherry Blossom.
Maybe we can get something special here.
And there's a creeper.
Hmm...
I have a...
I have a stone sword.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys!
Chat GPS.
Is this the ATM?
No, no, no!
Don't do it.
Don't do it!
Don't please!
Stop!
Stop coming towards me!
Don't do it!
Oh my god, you're so obsessed with me.
Wait...
Where's the slimes?
Or...
Oh wait!
No, yeah, where are the slimes?
Where are the slimes at?
Also, what's all this over here?
There's all the stuff that's lit up.
What is that?
Oh, it's the little...
This thingy.
This stuff.
Okay.
Aw man...
Creeper.
I really wanna get to this...
tree here.
If you could like...
give me some...
space.
I'm...
asserting my boundaries.
This is my first ever...
Akasupa.
Danny.
Thank you so much!
Became my copy O.C.
Thank you!
As I slowly back up from this guy.
LOL, this is my financial advisor.
No!
I'm gonna be a creeper because I'm real obsessed with me too.
Thank you, Marley!
Okay.
Boat jousting?
Oh, so true!
Alright, here we go.
And...
Brap!
I lived.
Where'd my boat go?
There it is!
Oh, there it goes.
And the sun's coming up!
I think.
We made it through the night!
We made it at our goal!
It's okay.
I have...
raw chicken.
That won't poison me.
Oops!
Super Chat doesn't like the office wifi.
What?
That's so bizarre.
I think that's a good reason not to Super Chat then.
I'd say.
Maybe.
Don't do it then.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, guys.
Let's get some cherry blossom trees.
For our worlds!
Please!
Come on!
Something dropped!
Drop the goods!
This is a stick up.
This is a hold up.
Drop the goods.
Give me everything.
That you own.
Back in the US after three months.
In Japan!
Three months!
Have some depression dollars.
Three months is...
Wait, what's this?
Wait.
Dark forest bio!
Okay.
Well, at least we got a new ingredient.
That's kind of the goal of this.
Is to keep collecting new ingredients.
Wi-Fi test.
Oh my gosh.
I'm Java hunting.
Can you fire that other one wisp and hire me?
Oh, that guy is like doing the best job we've ever had though.
He's my best man.
Oh!
Oh, sniffer!
Sniffer, sniffer!
Sniffer, sniffer.
Okay.
That's two new ones.
Two new ingredients.
Very cool.
And also, we need to get some dirt.
We need to get dirt.
Don't worry about my financial state.
Okay.
I do worry.
I do worry about you guys sometimes.
I need the...
Oh!
Another sniffer.
Wait, what's this?
Oh!
A third sniffer?
Four!
Guys, I don't think we're getting cherry blossom.
Oh my god!
Six of them!
Aw.
Wait, I wonder if we can also get...
Sand.
Did I just get another one?
Oh my god!
Let's dig up some sand too.
Let's just try and get all different new types of...
You know...
Material.
Oh.
I've hit the...
I've hit the rock.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Cherry blossom.
Sniffa.
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
I think the game is trying to tell me something.
Poopy!
Welcome back for 12 months, thank you.
Oh...
Okay, that's another dark forest, yeah.
Let's throw out...
This...
And...
Why is there a bat here?
Also, where is all this dirt coming from?
I'm giving...
Minto money, yippee!
Yip, yippee!
Heck yeah!
Why is there just...
There's dirt over there too?
Huh?
Why is there dirt over here?
Am I like...
Dropping...
Dirt?
Am I like...
Producing my own blocks of dirt?
What?
Follow the dirt?
Huh?
Is there still...
There might still be...
What's it called in there?
Yep.
I knew it.
You are Pigpen from Peanuts.
I'm disgusting!
How do I get more...
If I throw something out, do I produce dirt?
Turn into dirt.
Where does the dirt come from?
It's so mysterious...
Wait, there's dirt over there!
The dirt is mysterious and important...
Okay, well...
I...
What?
It's like...
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Finally rematerialize to celebrate a year of my Kamiyoshi!
Here's to another year of watching her so she can't flirt with my fiancee behind my back.
It would never stab me...
Oh my god!
How many Sniffers do we have?
Thirteen!
Where are these bats coming from?
This is so...
What is this?
Why is there...
Wait, are the bats bringing the dirt?
I...
This is so strange!
Dirt maxing...
They weren't kidding when they said we really like the dirt.
There's more dirt than more Sniffers!
The Sniffers, I've imagined, are not gonna give us like...
Any experience...
Another one!
Where is the dirt coming from?
Sorry, I know it's...
It's just...
It's just strange.
That's why I'm so confused by it.
But it gives us more points, so I'll take it.
Only found you everyday fuel.
Thank you!
That's all good!
Tasty?
The dirt?
We could...
Literally...
There's...
What?
Where did that come from?
No.
No, I saw it literally just spawn.
Okay, alright.
I think we're good to get out of here.
I think we're probably fine to get...
There's more.
Where did you come from?
Okay, I'm watching the bats.
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
I enjoyed watching and vibing with you and everyone...
Thank you!
Where did it come from?
I don't know!
Ah!
Scary!
It's so freaky!
I don't get it!
There's dirt over here!
I guess we'll just fill up our inventory with stuff and...
Take it over.
I've...
I'm freaking out right now, you guys.
I'm freaking out!
I'm freaking out a little bit!
I think the dirt comes from the skill you took.
Yeah, but I don't understand...
I don't understand why.
Why?
Does this give me a very little value?
You offer nothing to me, crafting table.
Okay.
Get two things...
Someone said get two stacks of dirt.
What, will it be a ton of XP?
We can go somewhere and just dig.
Let's go back towards where the...
Beacon was.
Unfortunately, we did not get any cherry blossom...
Thingies, but...
I also wanna see if maybe the...
I was gonna check out the flowers, too.
If that unlocks anything, because...
Um...
Yeah.
Well, we have unlocked some new stuff, at least.
Oh, and I can get chicken.
Good, because I need to eat.
Come here.
Yep, thank you.
What the?
Thank you.
Like, please, please, come here.
Oh, the dirt!
Where did it come from?
Thank you.
Oh, Sniffa.
Okay, I think breaking the flowers gives you more Sniffa.
Which we totally...
Totally need any more of these.
Oh, my chat is frozen.
One moment, please.
8 for 5.
Sniffa plus dirt is a freaky combo.
Freaky.
Thanks for thawing us.
You're welcome.
Okay.
Alright, dirt.
Let's grab some dirt.
I left my crafting table, because I'm a bozo head.
Guys, what's the...
What do I need to make a shovel?
What's...
The shovel?
Oh!
I'm a genius.
Never mind.
I'm too smart.
I'm too...
I'm too smart at this.
Just one block.
Getting lots and lots of dirt here.
Hopefully nothing spawns.
We'll be...
We're close to our...
We're close to the...
Boat.
It should be fine.
Oh, let's get rid of a flower.
There we go.
Pick up all my dirt.
Very important.
The reason we're here.
You should eat.
Yeah, you're right.
But I don't know the recipe.
You know what?
Risk it for the biscuit.
We're almost done anyway.
Eat the dirt.
Do the flowers give us any...
Oh, a point three.
I guess anything is good.
Maybe.
And that's two stacks.
Do I...
Does this give me anything?
Okay.
Let's go.
Hello.
See, we're fine.
Everything's all good.
Just keep...
Keep eating raw chicken.
You'll eventually recover.
Our stomach is strong.
It's mighty.
Here's more meatlobugs for...
The mine that you crafted...
That you...
Oh, thank you!
What if I...
What if I took...
Materials from...
The portal?
I wonder if I can do that.
Wow!
Woohoo!
31!
Let's go.
I think I got all of it.
Very nice.
Mine three.
Oh, we didn't get any trophies this time.
It's kind of sad.
One whole year of my coffee...
Oh, see!
Take your boost!
Thank you!
Mine four...
Base.
Oh, okay.
We got frogs and skellies.
Oh, no.
We got skellies.
Okay.
Um...
What do we wanna do?
I'll be going to an anime con in my city this weekend.
Fahana will be performing!
Lots of indie VTubers.
Woah!
I'll be repping you by wearing my Minto Happy.
Have fun, Verily!
Oh my gosh, Fahana is so fun to see.
Let's get some Sniffers!
We got so many of them, so...
Employed gang here.
Solid snake!
No way, you?
The legend is employed?
Wait, what do you mean you had an awful morning?
No!
I hope...
I hope you're okay.
We could...
It says base rock is deep slate, but maybe we should do...
Uh...
Maybe we should do...
Oh, jungle!
Wait, I want a jungle biome.
Wait...
Or...
Wait, I think a dark forest would be so bad with skellies.
Let's try the jungle.
The hero of Shadow Moses?
Let's see...
What's some new stuff?
Win a special encounter mod.
We haven't gotten that.
Collect mushrooms and you might get lucky.
Oh, okay!
A mushroom field biome!
That would be great!
Because we would have no...
No mobs!
No bad mobs!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Dry land.
Don't...
Try to get even warmer in the badlands.
What, set myself on fire?
Or...
One year!
Thank you, Cap'n!
Cap...
Cap'n!
Okay.
One HP.
Kill something while having only one heart.
Oh, I totally could have gotten that.
Snowy search code blocks.
Okay.
Bouncy blocks.
Find and kill some slimes.
Wait!
Then give me slime!
I want to find and kill the slime.
I didn't find any slime though.
Hmm.
We'll do that one next.
We'll get some slimes.
You have a slime egg.
Yeah.
But I...
They didn't appear last time.
They didn't appear...
There were supposed to be slimes in the last one we just did.
And we didn't get any.
Two!
One!
Bye-bye!
And...
Absolutely placing...
Whoa.
Ooh!
Oh my god!
Oh, get...
Get out of the water!
Why'd they put me in this tree?
Why do we start with an egg?
Oh!
Hello.
Why are you not upgrading?
Cause I forget.
Here, once I get out of this tree, I'll upgrade.
But also, I kinda wanted to get the fire upgrade.
But I guess I shouldn't.
My emergency chicken.
Okay.
Let's upgrade.
Let's see.
What do we want?
When do we want it?
Amphibian!
Oh, fast as the fish?
Wait.
That sounds pretty good actually.
Like...
Plus one jump.
Get more experience after each mine.
Load stone.
Double jump seems pretty good, no?
Ooh!
Whoa!
Even more jump.
More and more jump.
Isn't that a...
Project Sekai group?
Wait.
What is it like now?
Oh my god!
Wow!
More more jump!
The Lakers need you.
Get out of the mines!
I can't...
This is where I belong.
Need for speed.
Swift sneaking is pretty nice too, but...
I don't think we need it right now.
We'll...
Get more experience.
If you go down the lodestone path, you start with a compass.
Okay, I gotta get more experience then.
But with a compass to lead to the...
To the exit, right?
Alright.
I...
Oops.
I missed it.
This is so crazy.
Having...
Double jump...
In Minecraft.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry.
I'm getting a little lost in the sauce.
Let's...
Let's build a boat.
That's not what I meant to do.
At all.
There we go.
Okay.
And...
We need a crafting table.
This game...
This...
This version of Minecraft...
Oh, sorry.
Craft mine is going to force me to learn how these...
Recipes are.
You know?
Just...
Just grab that for now.
Hello, Mint.
Hello!
What are all these sniffers doing about?
I don't remember what the...
Oh, the sniffers give you eggs, right?
Hello, big boy.
Copper!
Wait!
Oh my god.
It's just one, but...
It's just one, but that's big.
Hold on.
Let's get some stone.
Because the copper can create the eye...
Of exit.
Where's the boat going?
I think you know.
Yeah, big ol' sniff.
I like how they're just all floating.
Why are they all floating in the water?
Actually, just a lurker behind me though.
Thank you for saying hi!
Hello!
Hello, Div.
Thank you for the super tattoo.
Two.
Oh.
Oh?
Wait.
Where'd all my stick go?
Oh, it's because I created two of these.
Okay.
Alright.
Throw you...
Oh.
It's fine.
I'll throw it away later.
Two!
Okay, we needed...
It was quite a bit, but that's not bad.
Two...
Two is good.
What was it?
I don't remember what the recipe was.
Eye of exit.
Iron.
Okay.
Get a furnace too?
So true!
So true.
Yeah, I'm just gonna use up my wood one.
I spent the materials on it.
I don't like wasting things, you know?
It's a waste.
Eight copper.
One iron for eye.
Thank you, Blaze.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for doing the math for me.
Oh, sorry.
I thought I saw...
I thought I saw some...
Uh...
Coal.
But it's those little deep slates in there.
Are you gonna dig anything for us, Mr. Sniffer?
No?
Okay.
Let's go search for...
Iron and...
Why are they all in the water?
Did not a single one spawn on land?
Okay.
That's fine.
I did.
Steffi!
Thank you for the gift.
Did.
Oh.
So much for our grand plan.
Go back.
There was more copper.
I don't think we need it.
Let's stay in this area.
Very nice.
Let's try and get some new recipes here.
Wait.
I wanna test my theory.
Oh.
Oh, this is the resin, no?
This is what...
Um...
The new...
The new creepy man.
What's his name?
What's that creepy guy called?
The...
The Reckoning.
The Creaking.
Let's see.
Maybe...
Maybe this drops some stuff?
It's kinda fun to see what drops...
Stuff and what doesn't.
Like, what drops...
Uh...
And what kind of ingredients...
Or seeds they drop, you know?
It's kinda fun to figure out, like, what...
Is going to...
Drop something useful.
Herobrine.
Also, ever since they added, like, the new bamboo wood...
I feel like bamboo might be the best in the game.
That's just my...
That's just my opinion.
You can collect so much of it.
So fast.
And make things so easy.
It might be the bestest.
The best material...
For wood in the game.
So OP.
I know!
They...
They really, like...
Oh my god!
They're on land!
Oh, thank goodness!
Okay, what were some of the...
What is that next to him?
Is that a frog?
Why is there a frog here?
Best vanilla wood.
Yeah.
What's some of the stuff that we could do to unlock things?
Uh...
Lurker lamb!
We're the...
Thank you.
Hope you're having a good time.
I'm having a grand time!
Thank you!
Let's just keep...
This is so satisfying.
Oh my god, it sounds amazing.
I guess not.
I guess nothing.
I feel...
Oh my goodness.
I feel like something would have spawned by now otherwise.
Are you gonna sniff for us?
Wait, what's that?
Oh, he got...
He did sniff for us!
He gave us a seed!
Can we see you raise a happy ghast?
Is that update out yet?
The ghast update.
I...
I'm running out of...
There's like no food around here.
How do I plant this thing?
Torch flower seed.
Plant.
It's in testing.
So if I did like the...
What's it?
Beta mode.
There's no food around...
Oh, there's a skelly in the tree.
Wait, where'd he go?
There he is.
I don't really want to deal with skellies, so maybe...
We just leave this world.
Thanks for tweeting about that Metal Gear concert.
Oh, did I?
Got a ticket.
Oh, have fun!
I don't think I tweeted about it.
But...
Maybe...
I think I liked the tweet and it might have shown up in your...
Thing.
That happens.
Well, let's take this too.
Wait, do you think this will break it?
Wait, what is this?
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Ouch!
No!
Oh, gee, the drama.
That was so...
I should have killed him so that I could get the achievement for it.
But it's okay.
Oh, that was so scary!
And I was gonna drown even too!
Small but deadly.
Better have good aim.
Oh!
It's a boss mine?
Wait, wait, wait.
I should have upgraded.
I'm an idiot.
Um...
My bad.
Whoa!
Next wave!
Wait.
What do you mean by that?
Oh God.
Ah!
Oh no!
Oh, silverfish!
Ew!
Oh my God, they're everywhere.
Wait, do I have to kill all these things?
I don't even have a sword!
There's no trees!
Are they dying?
I think some of them are dying in the water because it says mobs remaining.
Hold on.
Oh, pig!
One second, I'll come back to you.
Oh, they're just...
I think they're dying in the water.
They're drowning!
Oh, that's stupid.
Oh yeah!
Look at that!
They're perishing!
For what reason?
I actually don't quite know.
They're burrowing into the stove?
I don't think so.
Otherwise, they wouldn't remain.
Or they would still remain, no?
Okay.
I'll come back to you.
Let me get my...
Bamboo first.
God.
Double jump.
Forgot I had it.
Gotta go play D&D.
Oh, how fun!
Thanks for hanging out.
Despite...
Regardless, I gotta get...
I don't know how many waves there are, so we gotta get...
We gotta get a sword or...
Anything.
We gotta get anything!
Wait, how do I make this into wood?
Wait.
How do I...
I think I need an actual...
Tree.
They're still around, so...
We need a crafting table.
Okay.
We can do that.
We'll get a couple.
We'll get a little bits of wood.
Okay.
Alright.
That should be good for now.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's...
Boom.
Ba-da.
Bing.
Bam.
And...
Boom.
Oh!
Yeah!
Block.
Nice.
More block.
More.
Wow.
Okay.
Maybe you get a lot, but it doesn't give you so much.
And...
Sword.
Yup.
Okay.
Now...
Now we're cooking.
And I'll even get an axe.
With my axe.
Okay.
Eh.
Let's just go back.
If we die, we die.
Get food, too.
There's only chickens.
Please don't poison me.
Please.
Oh, god.
I had to fight for him.
You know what?
Actually...
Well...
Since...
Since these guys are not going anywhere.
The little...
What's it called?
The little endermites?
Or silver...
Silverfish?
What are they?
Endermites?
I just called them the actual creature.
Let's get the coal and we can...
Um...
Cook...
Something.
Oh, we can cook the food.
That's what I was like.
What was I gonna cook?
I'm cooking.
Endermites.
I know silverfish because I used to get them in my home.
Wait.
Nope.
Sorry.
I hate silverfish.
They're nasty creatures.
They're gross actually.
Okay.
Uh...
You.
And we can make a better sword too.
You know what?
Okay.
We're cooking.
We're literally...
Literally cooking.
Please.
Okay.
The other rule.
Alright.
Oh wait.
I need to make a furnace.
Okay.
We have to cook.
Oh, we're cooking.
Boom.
Can I get five big booms?
Oh and I was gonna make a new sword.
Eww.
Thank you.
Okay.
We'll keep the old one just in case we need it.
We got food.
We got blocks.
We're good.
Boom.
We're wisp guys.
Of course we watch Minto.
L-l-l-lava.
Ch-ch-ch-chicken.
That's not what this is, but it's okay anyway.
I can't believe they put, like, one of the redstone farms in the Minecraft movie.
It's so strange to me because it's, like, feels like such a fan-made thing, no?
So it's, like... It's so weird to me that it's in the movie.
All right, let's kill these guys.
Oh, really?
Yeah, that's what the l-l-l-lava chicken song is.
Come here.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Ew, ew, ew.
Okay, and...
Yeah, and...
Yeah, okay.
You over there.
Let me get my boat.
Why didn't they call it a bam boat?
You should...
You should work for Mojang.
Come here.
Disgusting.
Nasty creature.
Ew!
Oh!
They're buried!
Come here.
Come here, nasty.
Come here, stupid.
Oh, I'm the stupid one.
I'm the dumb one.
I'm just mean.
I'm the stupid one.
Come here.
Ouch.
I can't even hit you.
Stop bobbing up and down like that.
Okay.
Oh, there's one up top there.
How do I get to you?
He was the chosen one.
Hello?
Oh, oh!
That's how I get you.
Come here.
Oh, got him.
There's another guy.
Why...
Ouch!
Why are some of them not lit up?
Nasty!
The bar is not going down, unfortunately.
Hello?
Oh, there's a guy over there.
What kind of enemy is that?
This is a...
A...
Endermite.
Sometimes they spawn if you use an ender pearl.
Oh, there's more of them.
Come here.
No, it's a silverfish.
Wait, actually?
Oh.
Wait, is it actually?
Oh, it is a silverfish.
You're right.
Wait.
They look exactly like the endermite.
Next wave!
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I was right then.
The endermites are...
They're like a different color.
Or they're like purple, right?
Endermites are purple.
They make the same sound, though.
Here I thought I was being crazy.
Oh, here they come.
From the bottom of the sea.
Oh, more endermites!
I mean, silverfish!
I'm getting the name wrong.
Yeah!
Die, stupid!
This is so...
Stupid.
They're so slow.
I guess I could, you know...
Help them.
Ow!
He took over my boat!
Oh, God!
Wait!
This is piracy!
What is that?
No!
They're drowned even?
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die here for real.
They're drowned!
They're not even normal drowned.
They're baby drowned!
We're so...
We're so in trouble.
Ouch!
They're so strong!
Ugh!
Weak attack!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Got him.
Oh!
He dropped a bunch of stuff.
Wait, he dropped a bunch of stuff.
No?
Wait, ah!
My inventory!
Uh...
Okay.
Alright.
What am I keep collecting?
Oh, trophies.
I can't...
I think this is a chained...
Metal?
No, yeah.
It looks like a chained metal, too.
Alright, let's put my boat down.
Okay.
Alright.
Anything is better than nothing, though.
Buy more inventory.
You're so right.
Where's my...
Let's see.
Okay.
Yippee!
Let's double check, though.
Copper?
Is that a spitter?
Yes.
Wait, where'd all the ender...
I mean...
Silverfish.
What is that?
Is that a drowned?
That's a drowned.
He's coming.
Oh, they're coming this way!
Okay.
I hear him.
I hear him gurgling.
Ew!
He's so fast!
Yeah!
Ouch!
Why do you have such...
Why are your arms so long?
Whoa!
Ouch!
He's so fast!
I hear you!
Okay, we got one.
Brr-brr-brr-brr-brr...
Let's go...
Brr-brr-brr-brr...
How many more waves will there be?
Lose.
Die.
Die already.
Okay.
Get in my boat.
Pick up our...
Spoils...
Of war.
The gurgle, okay.
I thought I heard a gurgle.
Okay, there's more over here.
What are we getting?
Trophy.
Drowned.
Cute.
What's this?
No!
No spitter!
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
I think it'll be three waves.
Okay.
Maybe we get the guys on land.
I need some more chicken.
I need some more chicken soon.
Anyone on land?
No?
Oh my god, skellies.
Okay.
Come this way.
Oh my god, that guy just was like, I'm gonna take a little dip.
Okay.
All right.
Come here!
Come here, you!
Yeah!
Yeah, nice.
It makes them harder for you to swarm you.
Exactly.
I don't mind them actually being in the water.
It is a little awkward, but it's so much...
It's actually so much nicer...
...than if they were on land.
I'm not gonna lie.
Come here, single guy.
Come here.
Nice!
Okay?
Yes!
The trophies have random rarities.
Really?
Me?
Shit!
Are you calling...
You're calling yourself out?
I said nothing.
Come here!
Don't mind if...
If you insist...
I...
You know...
There's...
There's tons of fish in the sea.
As you can tell...
Little...
Tons of fish in the sea, huh?
Little silver fish...
I'm sure there's gold fish...
Uh...
Whatever your heart desires!
Not if you kill them all.
I can't help my...
Profession as...
Serial killer.
Now this is a single guy.
He might be our actual...
Only one left.
Next wave!
Look, there's a zombo over there.
There's a creeper right there.
We're so in trouble.
Do I have to find the exit too?
Or will it appear?
I wish I...
I wish the sun would come up.
Why does it feel like it's taking longer than normal?
I wish I had more chicken.
The exit will appear.
Okay.
Raise a hand if you want to get caught by me though.
What do you mean caught?
What am I?
The police?
We're gonna have them spawn in the water again.
50 creeper wave.
Don't say that.
Please be more...
Silver fish.
Thank you!
Wait...
Last time we got...
Zombie.
We got some drowns.
So what will it be this time?
Yeah!
More drowned!
Okay, I see three drowned.
I guess those guys went into the stone.
Wait, what the hell is that?
Uh-oh.
What was that?
What was the flying one?
What is that?
It's...
A fairy?
I think I can get this guy without getting caught by that skelly.
Yeah.
Come here.
A fairy.
Fairies aren't real.
Hell...
No, they aren't.
Fairies are not real.
You're absolutely right.
What?
Hey, hey, hey!
Get out of there!
Wait, it's got a pitchfork.
Whatever it is.
What is that?
Alright, let's take out as many of these little guys...
Let's take out the...
The less threatening things first, I suppose!
Oh gosh.
Yeah, don't be ridiculous.
Why would fairies be real?
Fairies!
Okay, hold on.
I don't know what this means, but I'm gonna use it.
Oh, it's a time.
Yippee!
Come up, little drowned, please.
Alright, this guy's coming over to me.
Come on, come on.
Slow and steady, I suppose, for this.
You can unequip the armor.
Oh, that...
Is that what it'll do?
I don't think I want to do that in this.
Oh, yep.
Now we can equip our own armor.
I think.
No more.
Kill, kill this feels very stupid.
That's good.
This is of my own doing, though.
Okay.
Why aren't those guys coming to get me, though?
The drowned.
Oh, they're gone.
Well, one of them is.
Was it actually a drowned?
Maybe it's a zombie in the...
In a cave?
Oh, what is that?
What did I just grab?
Oh, zombie.
Love that.
Oh, wait.
Maybe he's over there.
Wait.
Come out!
Come on out!
There he comes.
Oh, yeah.
Come on, zombie!
Where'd he go?
There he is.
He's shy.
Come on!
Oh!
Oh, why does he become so fast?
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
Die.
I don't care if you're a child.
Oh, ouch.
You have such long arms!
Okay.
All right.
There's an Enderman.
Oh, man.
This feels like...
I should...
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about the flying guys.
I wonder where they're at now.
Ouch!
Stupid.
Uh-oh.
My sword's gonna break soon.
Let's, um...
Maybe go find some more chicken.
Or something.
Let's go to the other side.
Let's go over this way.
Far away from where anything else was spawning.
We'll come back.
Probably.
Ah!
That's a thing.
That is gonna attack me.
Wait.
I don't...
I'm...
I'm not ready.
Wait.
I just want some chicken.
Please!
We're gonna go out to...
Go on a treasure hunt for these...
Other mobs.
Hold on.
Anything of...
Of...
Deliciousness over here?
Oh!
Something else died.
That's great.
It's a vex?
Oh...
Oh, wait.
Nothing else died.
It just, I guess, went out of range.
Love that.
Can I make cookies?
Increased FLV.
I see some sheep over there.
Hold on.
Wish I could make some armor.
What do I need?
Oh, some wheat.
I don't have that.
Hold on.
There's sheep.
We can at least kill that.
Come here.
This is like the slowest...
Oh, that's a cow.
Just kidding.
It's not a sheep at all.
Yippee!
Sorry.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's the slowest wave battle ever...
You'll ever experience.
I heard birds love cookies.
You guys act like we're gonna get birds.
You guys are fighting for my life out here.
And you're thinking about birds?
I'm trying to survive, and you're thinking about birds?
Wait, I want this.
There we go.
Okay, let's cook up some meat real quick.
Wait, there's another one.
And I'm gonna mine some more...
Stone as well.
Birds are surviving.
I'm trying to survive.
This cruel world out here.
This is why I'm dead.
It's too hard living.
This is how Kojima wanted the end fight to go.
I'm living out his vision.
He really was a visionary masterpiece.
We're genius.
Yeah.
It was...
The end fight would be a masterpiece.
Kojima!
I'll...
I'll do what you wanted to...
Accomplish!
Do these...
Do these cost a lot?
Or sell a lot?
I guess...
Where are they?
0.6.
Actually, that's not so bad.
Okay, we got five pieces...
Of meat.
Nice.
This is a crazy and cool April Fools update.
It's actually so much more expensive than I imagined it was going to be.
So it's...
Kind of actually insane.
Like how much they actually put into this.
You know?
I'm gonna leave some of my things over here.
So if we get into trouble...
We'll just...
This will be our safe haven.
I wish.
Sword.
Okay, get rid of you.
Alright.
An outer haven.
If you will.
Yes.
Actually, let's keep my sword.
Where'd I put it?
Oh, there's chicken!
Where'd the...
Where'd the chicken meat go?
Oh, there it is.
I don't remember killing that.
But I believe it.
I believe I did that.
Ah!
Sorry.
I thought I was dead.
I thought that was it.
I thought that was the end of my...
End of my Minecraft life.
Oh wait.
I guess I can leave this here too.
Since I...
Yeah.
We'll...
We'll just have it on hand for...
We could kill...
And then get more meat and...
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
I don't know how you guys do it.
Living.
Like knowing that...
Anything could come up to you and kill you.
You guys do that every day!
Wow.
Alright.
Back to the...
Grueling...
Endermite...
Elimination...
Um...
Process.
Okay.
That takes care of that guy.
There's so many mobs remaining.
We're like just a little under halfway.
Some of them are ghosts?
What do you mean?
What?
Ghosts are gonna kill you?
No.
Living can be hard.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
It's like...
They're like so sniffly.
Sounds like they're just sniffling their nose.
You guys got bad allergies?
Pollen this here is quite crazy, eh?
Sniff, sniff, sniff!
More sniffing than the sniffa.
Uh oh, it's starting to get dark again.
Oh gosh, please.
Don't do this to me.
Actually, at least we were able to make our stuff in the daytime.
Like our little...
Our little area.
Come here!
Alright.
Slow and steady, eh?
I wonder how many...
Oh my god, there's so many over there.
I wonder how many of the flying guys there are.
Do you think the flying guys will be hard to beat?
Howdy, minto and chat.
Howdy.
I'm doing a raid, but it's like the slowest raid...
You'll ever experience, ever.
Oh, do they come up in the night?
Is that what it is?
In the daytime, they just chill down there.
Oh, I think they're coming.
Oh yeah, they're coming.
Oh yeah, they're on their way.
Oh yeah, they're fast.
Watching this on full volume...
Full volume...
While Fam is sleeping next door.
Oh, sorry.
I'll try to be quiet.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
That was a good sweet.
Good sweet.
Sweet.
Hello?
Everyone's telling me about Ily Joel Aspen!
You guys are the best.
Might be the funniest thing ever.
My arch nemesis...
Got arrested!
Woo!
Okay.
But now we wait until morning to kill...
These guys.
Unless...
He can come out to the ocean.
Cause I...
There's no way in hell I'm getting on land...
And fighting that thing...
At night.
Look at all those skellies!
Look how many there are!
Where did he go?
Don't tell me they just like took off.
You think they left?
I have to go exploring for them!
Oh no.
Don't you have wool for a bed?
I don't think that they'll let you make a bed.
That's the thing.
Or rather, you can make a bed.
I don't think that you can sleep.
Oh my god.
This bozo over here thinks he's part of the party.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
He's gonna turn into a drowned!
Yeah, they don't really let you sleep in this mode.
Oh!
Let's go around.
Another guy?
I think he's not in...
Wait, was he coming?
Is he on his way?
He looks like he's getting closer.
They'll die of old age in a week.
They went for milk!
Oh yeah.
He's on his way.
Look at him.
He's flexing on us.
Fortnite emoting.
Woo!
12.
Ballerina Caputina.
Come here.
Come here ugly.
Stupid baby.
Yeah, stupid baby.
Okay.
Are you guys having a good week?
It's...
Maybe Thursday for some of you?
Maybe Friday for some of you?
Having a good time?
Water jockey.
What did that baby do to me?
He flexed on me and I actually really didn't appreciate it.
I thought it was quite rude.
Having an alright week.
It's almost the weekend.
Once it's the weekend, you made it!
You made it through the week.
And then next week could be good.
You got a new pet?
Newt?
Oh my god.
Wait.
There was a...
There was a lizard that I saw.
That people were saying that they're like really great pets.
Because they're just like...
Wait, wait a second.
Wait, hold on.
Oh my god.
No way.
Yes!
Sorry.
I was...
Hold on.
I'll explain in just a second.
Um...
There was a...
A lizard that I saw.
People were saying that it's like a dog.
And I...
I'm like...
Oh my gosh.
I really don't have time to care for a lizard.
But...
He's just so cute!
Hold on.
I saved him.
Where...
I saved what he's called.
Hold on.
I thought I did.
Oh no.
Did it...
Maybe the video got deleted.
No way!
No!
Wait.
Maybe it's further down.
No!
Did I...
Did I not save it for real?
They were like...
These...
These lizards are so cute.
They're like...
Dogs.
They're kind of like...
Apparently invading...
Invading Miami right now.
I guess maybe someone got one as a pet.
And then...
You know how it goes.
People get things as pets.
And then they don't realize...
Like the amount of work that goes into them.
And they just release them into the wild for some reason!
I...
Was it a no...
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Let me double check.
If I see it, I'll remember.
No...
Hold on.
That actually seems right.
Because they're big.
They're really big, guys.
This might be it.
Yes!
Yeah!
The Tegu?
Tegu?
Lizard?
Oh my gosh.
Tegu?
That guy!
He's so cute!
Oh my gosh.
They're so stinking cute.
Tegu.
Tegu!
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh.
I want one so bad.
And I keep seeing videos of like...
It'll be like my Tegu lizard wants to cuddle with the cats.
But the cats don't want to cuddle with the Tegu lizard.
Oh my gosh.
I want one.
They're like puppies.
They're so cute.
Oh gosh.
I want one so bad.
They're so cute.
But...
I don't think I can care...
I don't think I can take care of one.
Oh my gosh.
They're so cute.
I love lizard.
They're massive.
Yeah.
They're really, really big.
And apparently they're like...
Kind of an invasive species.
And they're like kind of...
Um...
Yeah.
Not supposed to be where they're currently at.
But yeah.
Uh...
Yeah.
Don't cry Minto.
Sorry.
I think about lizard and I cry.
Scaly puppies.
I want one so bad.
Maybe if I didn't have cats.
Cause I don't think my cats would...
Maybe they would warm up to it.
I don't know.
Cats and dogs are also invasive species.
Oh my god.
Cats are extremely invasive.
Cats are very invasive.
They'll wipe out a whole population.
If you don't release them, it shouldn't matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's so sad when people do that with their pets.
Makes me so sad.
Okay.
Alright.
It's date time, baby.
Alright, we're back in business.
Sorry for the...
We...
We took a little break.
Now we're off to go find these other things that need to be killed.
Okay.
Land!
I hate how smart skellies are in this game.
Okay.
Maybe not land.
Sorry.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
He was so fast.
Oh my gosh.
Iron!
What?
This might be huge.
This might be...
Big...
Big update.
A big update.
Is there only one?
Please say no.
Please say psych.
There's two.
Where could it have gone?
The other mobs.
Look at him over there.
Menacingly.
Where could they have gone?
They flew off into...
Who knows where?
Enough for a sword.
Sword or shield.
I think a shield would be more important here, no?
Especially against these...
Guys?
Let's search this area a little bit more.
For more coal.
Coal!
Coal.
Oh, that's a pig.
That's a pig.
I thought that was a...
Sheep.
I can't get used to the new colors.
Now we'll grab some more...
Coal.
I mean, not coal.
I need iron.
Why am I saying coal?
Okay.
Iron!
A wisp pet review.
The moment you are...
Oh, wait.
That one moment of you crying over a cute bird shortly after return is my go-to clip whenever I'm down.
Are my tears...
Are my tears enjoyment for you?
Tovek!
Ouch!
Oh my god!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is all...
Gravel.
Double jump is double scary.
With great power comes great responsibility, I guess.
It's all gravel!
I don't see anymore.
Not like at a quick glance.
Are you not entertained?
Look!
Wait!
Oh, I think the meter is going down because we're getting out of range.
Wait, what if it goes down all the way?
What if I get so out of range that it disappears?
I don't think that's how that works though, is it?
Wait, what is that?
No way!
Is that one of those like sunken...
Like underground...
Pottery...
Barns?
Pottery houses?
Pottery...
Dig site?
It's a submarine.
It looks kind of like a submarine.
What is that?
No.
This is not a boat.
You are incorrect.
This is...
What the hell?
This is a structure.
What?
Oh!
Sussy!
Sussy...
Mysterious...
Gravel!
Okay, time to go all the way back.
Is that a...
Ruined portal?
Wait, can we get to the nether?
No, what?
Wait, there might be some good resources in there though.
I'm gonna end up getting lost, I think.
Nether is disabled.
No nether.
Interesting.
Okay.
Good to know.
I don't wanna waste my food by just running around, you know?
That's why we cook some more.
Baby.
Let's see if there's any good supplies up in there.
And also, let's grab some chicken.
Nice.
Wait.
I love...
I love nether portals that spawn by...
Jungle biomes.
Cuz they're so neat looking.
Oh, we did get a lodestone.
We'll keep...
This.
I guess.
Okay.
No armor.
But maybe the lodestone doesn't do anything here.
Because the exit will appear, no?
Wow!
Gosher!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 15th.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa!
Never see emerald just random.
We are so fast.
We could go faster.
Wait.
Actually, I wanna upgrade the like a fish.
Which one was that?
Fish, fish, fish, fish.
Fish.
A fast is a fish.
Let's get that.
The raid is over.
Wait, did it actually...
Did I...
Did I work?
Did it work?
Wait, you're right.
It's gone.
So weird seeing the double jump.
I know.
Me too.
Wait.
Oh yeah, there's the thing.
Mito wins by doing absolutely nothing.
Take more...
Get more jump.
Can I?
Wait, is it in the sky?
No.
Why did you...
No way.
Wait a second.
We take those?
No!
Why is it in the sky?
Wait.
Oh, plus one jump.
Okay, we'll save up for 24.
Oh my god, it ended.
We did it, guys.
They just...
They really just said we give up.
Oh my gosh, how do I get up here?
The game!
They're like, hey, if you want this exit, you work for it.
You have to do something, Mito.
You can't just do nothing.
And expect to...
Expect to win.
Yes, sir.
Hold on, let's get some dirt, maybe.
We did it!
Wow!
You think, actually, with all that I have combined...
This and...
This...
You think I can even get up there?
Maybe?
I don't think so.
I think I need some dirt.
That was quite the boss battle.
Oh yeah.
You know, I...
You know me, I'm known for...
I'm known for...
Having really epic final boss battles and...
Getting them done...
In really epic...
Awesome ways.
It's so funny...
Uh...
I have so many people...
Not so many...
A few...
A handful of comments...
On the...
If you watched...
The...
My last part of Devil May Cry 4...
Of just people that are really mad about how I...
How I beat some of the bosses...
They're just...
Oh, ouch.
They're just like...
This is so unfair!
Yeah, I have...
I have people that are...
Like...
Sorry...
I...
I just...
I don't know...
Oh, wait!
That's the dirt!
Where did that come from?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I might not have enough.
Oh, yes I do.
Oh!
Oops.
I miscalculated...
By a bit.
There we go.
Yay!
Alright!
Um...
Let's leave.
Finally.
Woohoo!
They don't...
Just to...
Just to make it clear...
They don't...
Uh...
The comments don't bother me or anything.
I think it's kind of fun...
Master key...
It's...
You know...
I can understand from both sides...
Like...
Why it would be frustrating...
But...
I mean...
If the game didn't want me to play it...
Like...
Why would they allow it?
Are you winning, Minto?
Somehow!
Look at this!
Because we've got...
Seven!
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
What's this trophy?
Oops...
Oh, another one...
Wait, where did you come from?
Oh...
Okay...
Different...
Rarity, maybe?
Should we?
What's the key go to?
Oh!
Oh...
Dang ...
Now we can add more stuff!
Wait...
I don't want to play for so much longer just because...
I'm going to be on Doki's channel later.
What's this?
Oh, Spitter.
So many years of bad luck from this one.
Maybe a dark forest bio.
And slimes.
And...
More...
No.
Ew, there's...
Oh, there's skellies in here?
Okay, we might die here, guys.
But that's okay if we do.
And frogs.
If I die here, that's okay, actually.
Because I want to go eat before...
Before next.
Where we at, baby?
This is so cool.
What I really wanted to look forward to...
Was like...
You can get some really wacky...
Um...
Like...
Worlds in this.
If you like...
Get...
Collect enough stuff.
Like, you can make everything wool, apparently.
I wanted to get the...
Actually...
Actually, we might be able to get the mushroom...
Mushroom one.
Wait, this is so messed up.
How am I supposed to get down from here?
I'm...
I'm 100% going to take damage.
This is messed up.
Game.
Ouch.
Okay, well...
I wanted the mushroom one.
Yeah, but you can get some really crazy ones.
Double jump will cancel.
Fall down.
What?
No way.
Ouch!
I didn't realize that would happen.
Here, let's try...
Let's test it.
Oh...
Um...
I'm just...
I'm just going somewhere.
I should probably collect...
Wood.
I should probably play the game.
It's the most powerful tool.
It seriously is!
Wow, this is such a cool...
Ah!
The goal here is mushrooms.
Let's get some mushroom.
But yeah, I was hoping that maybe...
I mean, it's also the way I play.
I'm very slow.
You guys know this, though.
Probably by now.
I take everything so slowly.
But...
Maybe we can play this time...
Sometime again.
And...
Go through some crazy...
Oh no!
Dang it!
Some crazy...
Get some crazy...
Worlds.
This is very...
Not like what I expected, though.
From...
I thought...
I thought it would be more like...
I thought it would be less of a...
It's like a...
It's its own game.
You know?
It's crazy.
I want the mushroom.
I want the mushroom biome.
And this was all just for April Fools.
I'm like...
This is actually so...
Impressive.
Just for...
It's like a little stupid April Fools thing.
I...
I am...
I am pleased.
And it's free!
So...
Well, I mean as long as you have Minecraft.
So I think that's just a little neat.
I sound like I'm shilling it.
It's like...
I think...
Fun things are fun.
You know?
I like the different kind of biomes...
Or worlds you can make in this too.
Cause it's very...
It's like...
It feels like it's hacked.
Like look at all the deep slate.
It feels like...
A mod for real.
Fun things are fun.
Exactly!
So if I can show you something new and fun...
That's...
You know.
Worth it to me baby.
Okay.
I think I will cut it here though.
So let me get to land.
Let me get to land.
We can check this out again sometime though.
For sure.
I wonder if you can use the seeds in the normal game.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Let's finish up my...
Oh wait.
No, I was gonna...
I'm saving up.
For the double jump.
For the triple jump?
I know there is...
I did see the one that starts you with the pickaxe.
Wait.
I did?
I thought I did.
Oh, this one, right?
Oh, it's only two.
Mining efficiency.
Okay.
I spent all my levels.
Oh, animals killed have a chance of dropping extra loot.
Wait, hold on.
Check it.
I know I need to...
Actually play.
But can I get one for mining like snow?
Or do I need to like use a sil...
Okay.
Sorry.
Get me out of here.
Get me.
I need to stop playing the game.
I can't stop playing.
Flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
Okay.
I got held up at work so I'm late.
But it's my birthday Alfredo!
Can I get a MGS happy birthday to celebrate?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
With salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Alfredo!
You caught me just at the end.
Lucky, lucky.
Thank you guys for...
Minecraft!
No!
Craft mine!
I hope you guys have fun.
And...
This was fun for me!
Yeah!
I will see you guys when...
Oh, maybe at Doki?
We can raid the waiting room I suppose.
That would be fun.
Doki waiting room.
Raid.
Um...
Redirect.
Doki Doki.
So if you know...
If you wanna know where I'm gonna be...
Wait, did she make a waiting room yet?
Oh...
Yes!
Okay, she did.
What did she mean, scaredy cats?
She don't love meeting with you!
Anyway...
Atsubito!
Thank you guys!
Eat that asha!
Have a great day!
Have a great night!
And I will see you guys...
LATER!
Thank you so much for...
Craft mine!
Bye-bye!